well let's bring you some breaking news  just coming in to us now following that  announcement from the foreign office of  sending more aid to help  with that situation in india foreign  secretary dominic  raab has just tweeted that uh today we  have sent the first of several urgent  deliveries of surplus medical equipment  to our friends in india to help provide  life-saving care  for vulnerable coveted patients no one  is safe  until we are all safe that tweet from  foreign secretary  dominic rob in the last few moments as  the foreign office announces that it's  sending ventilators  and oxygen concentrator devices to india